The second core service of course is CPU scheduling. And
exokernel in order to facilitate this core service, maintains
a linear vector of time slots. So, time is divided into these
epochs T1, T2, T3 and so on, and every time quantum has a begin and an
end. And these time quantums represent the time
that is allocated to the library operating systems
that live on top of exokernel. And the
time quantum is bound by the begin end
markers for each library operating system. Each library operating
system gets to mark its time quantum at
startup in this linear vector of time slots.
So, for instance, OS1 may say that I get this time slot, I get this time slot,
maybe some of the time slot and so on.
And similarly, OS2 marks its spots in the linear
vector time slots. So CPU scheduling in exokernel is
essentially looking at this linear vector of time slots and
asking the question, in this time quantum, which is
the library operating system that should be running on the
processor? And there is a start time for the
time quantum. There's an end time for the time quantum.
And Let's say, OS1 is now running on the CPU. When the timer interrupt goes
off, at this endpoint, control is transferred
by exokernal to the library operating system to
do any saving that it has to do of the context. And the time that is
allowed for a library operating system to do the saving and restoring of context
at the point of a context switch is
bounded. And if an operating system misbehaves, let's say
that OS1, when exokernel says it's time for you
to save your context and give back the processor
to me so that I can schedule it,
for some of the operating systems. And let's say
OS1 takes more time than is allowed to at
the point of this context, which, in that case,
what will happen is exokernel will remember that
OS1 misbehaved And it will take time off of
OS1 the next time it is scheduled. For there's
a penalty associated with exceeding the time quantum. The
time quantum is bound. During this time quantum, OS1
has complete control of the processor, and exokernel is
not going to get in the middle of it, unless
a process that is running on behalf of OS1
incurs a page fault. In that case, exokernel has
to come in the middle in order to field
that page fault and pass it up to the
operating system. And otherwise, during this time quantum, the operating
system is entirely at liberty to use a processor
for running whatever processes it wants to. At the
end of the time quantum, the time integer goes
off. Exokernel feels it and kicks it up to the
operating system and tells the operating system to clean up its act. Save
any context it wants so that the CPU can be reallocated to the next library
operating system. And that's where the time is bounded, as to how much time
the library operating system can take in order to do that saving of the context.